bournemouth's bunting on coronation day
to burton joyce in nottinghamshire
we've long marked the monarch's
milestones britain jubilant joyful and
just a little eccentric
this is the village of horsted canes in
west sussex the year
1953 the children all dressed up for the
occasion
not much has changed today with events
taking place on the same green i love
fancy dress
and this film inspiring the platinum
party planners it's just nice to just
bring it all bring everyone back
together again against especially after
what's been happening the last few years
um everyone really needs it um
you know just to all of us to just pull
together and have some nice time really
so to make the bunting this is what i
did last time from sussex to sheffield
it's just a matter of stapling it to the
string lisa moorman's streets making
bunting i just remember everyone being
so excited here she is in
1977 enjoying the silver jubilee they
had all of the street parties they got
all the children out
and it was just a great occasion i
remember that and hopefully let's do
something similar for our children to
remember to pass on to theirs
this park in preston's promising
england's biggest party a mellow and
multicultural meal for 600.
preston is so diverse it's got a lot of
fun
a different ethnic minority community
groups
in in the location so it was important
to reflect the residents of preston to
be here and let them feel part of this
national celebration
some streets saw the forecast and
brought their parties forward a day
waterproof bunting here in shirley
they've been buying waterproofs and
umbrellas we're just improvising with as
much uh plastic above head as possible
that we can get on a budget
because it's going to be a real shame if
people just sort of come and everyone's
huddled under their umbrellas and
looking all miserable we want everyone
to be happy
whatever the weather parties are playing
out across the uk remembering and
reminiscing 70 years of rain
laura bundock sky news in horstead
keynes